[Musique]
aouita franck web en 2015 émeut toujours
son public président barack obama
une des grandes voix de l'amérique avec
un répertoire qui nourrit l'espoir et la
liberté
né à memphis en 1942 elle grandit à
detroit avec son père un pasteur très
jeunes doués et joue du piano et chante
dans la chorale gospel de son église
puis elle verse dans l'euro 2012
[Musique]
1967 marque le début de son immense
carrière et l'enregistrent un très grand
succès son interprétation de la chanson
i will speck en fait un igloo mouvement
des droits civils du pasteur martin
luther king le devient une des
ambassadrices de la lutte des noirs
[Musique]
dans les années 80 2 reprend l'avant
scène avec brio et celui moment du
numéro avec fougue étude dénommée
science
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hier
[Applaudissements]
en 1987 elle devient la première femme
est remisé au fond une des icônes de la
musique noire américaine
et
[Musique]
elle vivra de son art pendant cinq
décennies
[Musique]
rieter franklyn connaissent et montréal
elle a souvent chanté au festival de
jazz au cours de sa longue carrière
cette femme de talent a remporté 18 prix
grammy et a su inspirer plusieurs
générations
ici seuls des mulets radio canada
montréal
[Musique]